foreign
was for me pretty difficult to find out
how much I would emphasis on the emotion
you can destroy with music very quickly
the intimacy
[Music]
we record it with a full-on 40-string
Orchestra and then I used the filter
that cut everything off on top of that
we could hear every breath it was a
little bit like the inner voice
we knew we were going to use the lineup
of a jazz band but we didn't want to
feel like 20s Jazz so we talked about
the feeling of rock and roll we wanted a
lot of really heavy driving riffs
and then we would give it to Unison
horns and it would give this real
muscularity to it
[Music]
it still leaves the question how much
does the music want to say about what's
going on
I try not to get ahead of the characters
of what they're feeling and experiencing
but still treated very subjectively from
their point of view
[Music]
the laundry and taxes queue that was one
of the most tricky scenes to score
because it was so significant a moment
emotionally
[Music]
that just called for a kind of effusive
giving in to The Melancholy and the
sweetness
[Music]
composing for me is really like
sculpting and when you really take a
chunk out of the stone and other chunk
and finally it reveals itself
[Music]
it isn't the music it isn't the
orchestra it isn't the composer it is
this interconnection of all these
elements that makes music music
[Music]